Je pense que j'aimerais avoir tes cheveux c'est
ta couleur naturelle c'est tellement
beau ne penses-tu pas qu'elle est
juste parfaite c'est que ton vrai nez ouais la
vie est si
injuste tu viens de sortir de l'atelier de carrosserie
elle est encore un peu sensible
tu as fait du travail tu dis que comme si c'était
une mauvaise chose ma chérie les plastiques sont juste un
bon toilettage imaginez passer un an
sans vous brosser les dents Je vais chez ce
gars à Beverly Hills
Andrew dr.  Andrew elle est amoureuse d'
eux bien sûr je les aime regarde moi
il m'appelle la femme bionique a envoyé un
compliment
j'entends que tes parents sont morts ça doit
être vraiment dur pour toi tu as une autre
famille non personne du tout
tu dois avoir un  petit ami
tout ce qu'elle veut vraiment savoir c'est qui
tu es [ __ ] désolé